[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pasado 1 de julio de 2017 se celebró
el 150 cumpleaños de canadá os lo
contamos aquí en visual político en un
vídeo donde también os mostramos las
claves de por que canadá es uno de los
países más admirados de todo el mundo el
instituto fraser publica un estudio el
índice de libertad humana que mide tanto
las libertades económicas como las
libertades civiles es decir mide lo que
las personas podemos hacer y no hacer
pues bien según este estudio canadá es
el sexto país más libre de todo el
planeta sin embargo aunque este país ha
cumplido 150 años en plena forma también
se enfrenta a problemas y amenazas
sociales políticas y económicas que en
algunos casos pueden considerarse muy
como decirlo bastante serias y es que ya
lo sabéis nunca nada es completamente de
color de rosas pues bien si en el
anterior vídeo cuyo enlace por cierto os
dejo al final de este y también en la
descripción nos centramos en las luces
en este vamos a acercarnos a las
principales sombras y amenazas que se
ciernen sobre canadá y la primera de
ellas
tiene mucho que ver precisamente con
este 150 cumpleaños
[Música]
un cumpleaños un tanto artificial
no todos los canadienses ni muchísimo
menos han celebrado este aniversario
podemos encontrar diferentes razones
pero para explicarlo lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es ver que se ha
celebrado exactamente con este
aniversario así que echemos la vista
atrás en el tiempo y vayamos hasta 1867
el 1 de julio de ese año cuando como
todos sabéis este territorio continuaba
formando parte del imperio británico se
firmó la primera acta británica para
norteamérica la british north america
act de 1867 fue una ley que unió a las
entonces tres provincias coloniales de
nueva brunswick nueva escocia en canadá
que ese mismo día por cierto se dividió
en ontario y québec en la confederación
de canadá
pues bien sobre estas cuatro provincias
que mantuvieron bastante autonomía se
colocó un gobierno federal que las diese
cierta cohesión por supuesto sobre este
gobierno federal continuaban estando las
autoridades británicas de hecho canadá
sigue siendo a día de hoy una monarquía
y la reina de inglaterra isabel segunda
sigue ocupando la jefatura del estado es
más aunque parezca sorprendente y de
facto la autonomía fuese total canadá no
alcanzó la plena independencia del reino
unido- hasta prácticamente antes de ayer
hasta 1982 si tal como lo escucháis
hasta 1982 cualquier modificación
constitucional requería formalmente del
visto bueno de las autoridades
británicas el caso como veis es que la
ley de 1867 no dio lugar a un país
independiente y si encima tenemos en
cuenta que todo el proceso fue llevado a
cabo por la minoría que formaban la
élite blanca ya podemos comprender por
qué muchos colectivos no están
precisamente entusiasmados con este
aniversario y sobre
el más importante es el de los pueblos
precoloniales porque amigos
canadá no era una tierra vacía
las primeras naciones los inuits y los
matisse
cerca de millón y medio de canadienses
no tuvieron nada que celebrar el pasado
1 de julio hablamos de las personas que
pertenecen a los pueblos indígenas en
este aniversario es una celebración de
los peores 150 años de vida de los
pueblos indígenas pero no penséis que se
trata de un problema histórico para nada
el reconocimiento y la integración de
estos pueblos aún sigue siendo un
problema nacional de hecho el gobierno
de justin crudo lo considera como una
prioridad fijaos lo claro que fue el
propio primer ministro el pasado 21 de
junio de 2017 el día nacional de los
aborígenes ninguna relación es más
importante para nuestro gobierno y para
canadá que la de los pueblos indígenas
pero claro puede que os estáis
preguntando quiénes son estos grupos y
qué problemas han sufrido
[Música]
pues bien según la propia constitución
de canadá hablamos de tres grandes
grupos las primeras naciones que
comprenden más de 600 comunidades indias
los inuits que como todos sabemos eran y
son los pobladores del ártico y los may
tis resultado de la mezcla de aborígenes
y colonos y es que amigos que a nava
cuando llegaron los colonos europeos no
era para nada una tierra vacía se estima
que por aquel entonces vivían unas 500
mil personas pertenecientes a estos
pueblos indígenas que firmaron acuerdos
con las autoridades francesas y
británicas de hecho llegaron a
participar en batallas para proteger la
propia independencia de canadá canadá
sería estadounidense hoy si no fuera por
los aliados indios que lucharon por la
corona si los eeuu trataron de invadir
canadá en alguna que otra ocasión pues
bien el caso es que a pesar de ser
pobladores de estos territorios antes de
la llegada de los colonos y de
contribuir a la independencia de este
territorio
los indígenas sufrieron una auténtica
persecución cultural
así es fruto de esta obsesión que
algunos tienen por crear identidades
homogéneas y nacionales por encima de
todo en canadá se desató toda una
persecución contra el indio durante años
los pueblos indígenas sufrieron la
ocupación de sus territorios y se les
concentró en reservas que a decir verdad
en muchos casos no reunían siquiera las
mínimas condiciones para garantizar la
supervivencia de estas personas asimismo
tanto sus lenguas como sus ritos
religiosos y culturales fueron
perseguidos y en muchos casos prohibidos
esta obsesión por la ingeniería social
llegó hasta tal punto que las
autoridades pusieron en marcha un
sistema de residencias e internados para
niños de estas familias indígenas el
gobierno le quitaba a los niños a las
familias y los internaba en estos
lugares para que recibiesen una
educación estrictamente occidental y
perdieran así cualquier rasgo de su
cultura decenas de miles de niños
pasaron por estos lugares
y ojo porque estos colegios estuvieron
funcionando hasta los 70 y claro las
consecuencias llegan hasta hoy tasas de
pobreza muy por encima de la media
familias rotas depresiones alcoholismo o
tasas de suicidios también anormalmente
altas
[Música]
estas son amigos las consecuencias de la
ingeniería social y junto a ello el
racismo y la exclusión
también fueron habituales aún hoy
existen muchos casos criminales por
resolver algunos por cierto cometidos no
hace tanto tiempo
[Música]
en 2008 el entonces primer ministro
stephen harper pidió perdón a estos
pueblos por los atropellos cometidos y
se estableció la comisión de la verdad y
la reconciliación
también han pagado cientos de millones
en indemnizaciones a la comunidad pero
eso por si mismo nunca arregla los
problemas
el caso es que hoy este nuevo canadá aún
busca la mejor manera de pasar página y
de este conflicto social y político
pasemos a uno de mucha mayor actualidad
eeuu y donald trump
la amenaza de ruptura canadá amigos es
un país muy dependiente de su relación
con los eeuu tanto que casi podríamos
decir que los canadienses no podrían
vivir sin sus vecinos los yankees fijaos
casi el 70% de todo el comercio
canadiense se dirige a su vecino del sur
y no sólo eso el sector industrial de
este país también está tremendamente
interconectado con el de eeuu
vamos que la relación es muy especial y
esto es algo que ya se introdujo lo ha
tenido siempre bastante claro lo dijo en
campaña y nada más llegar al poder
concentro buena parte de la agenda
internacional en tratar de mejorar aún
más sus relaciones con eeuu y la verdad
el tándem que formó con obama fue casi
de película
[Música]
sostén tiguan mayor leadership and your
friend ser inaugurado con chris canetti
ratings working together saláis
[Música]
el sun-times muy bien primero y
josh bard
es verdad hacking
[Música]
pero en esas llegó al poder donald trump
con toda su retórica proteccionista
y que hizo el gobierno canadiense pues
atentos montar una especie de sala de
guerra de oficina dedicada a seguir
todos los pasos de la nueva
administración de washington al
principio la estrategia de crudo hacia
el nuevo presidente y su entorno fue la
seducción y todo se ha dicho parece que
la cosa funcionó el primer ministro
canadiense incluso logró trazar amistad
con ivanka trump la propia hija del
nuevo inquilino de la casa blanca
ivanka trump se va al teatro con justin
truco lo que ya os podéis imaginar dio
rienda suelta a todo tipo de
especulaciones el caso de esquivó
química y ambos lideraron un panel sobre
mujeres y negocios del que se hizo eco
el propio donald trump en el mismísimo
discurso ante el congreso con la ayuda
del primer ministro justin crudo hemos
firmado un comité con nuestros vecinos
en canadá para asegurarnos de ayudar a
las mujeres emprendedoras a tener acceso
a redes mercados y al capital necesario
para iniciar sus negocios y alcanzar sus
sueños financieros vamos que todo
parecía ir viento en popa pero esperad
un momento porque de repente un buen día
como quien no quiere la cosa
donald trump se lanzó al cuello
canadiense y les acusó de competencia
desleal algo que como todos bien sabéis
también ha hecho con mexico pues bien
ante el peligro que supondría para
canadá una restricción en las relaciones
comerciales entre ambos países el
gobierno de ottawa no se amilanó y lanzó
la que ha sido bautizada como estrategia
donut esta estrategia consiste en
influir sobre todos los órganos de
washington alrededor de la casa blanca
que se situaría claro en el agujero del
donut
congresistas senadores e incluso
gobernadores los funcionarios y
políticos canadienses han comenzado una
auténtica gira por los eeuu
de momento parece estar funcionando y el
apoyo en washington hacia canadá parece
crecido pero sólo el tiempo nos dirá
cómo termina la renegociación del nafta
que fijará los nuevos términos en las
relaciones comerciales entre ambos
países ahora la pregunta es conseguirán
su objetivo pues bien la siguiente etapa
que nos espera es una potencial crisis
que según cada vez más expertos puede
estar amenazando la prosperidad
canadiense
[Música]
y la burbuja inmobiliaria
en las últimas décadas los precios de
las casas encarnadas se han disparado
como un cohete han crecido un 76 por
ciento al tiempo que los préstamos
bancarios también se han disparado hoy
la deuda de las familias canadienses se
encuentra entre las más altas del mundo
fijaos en este gráfico para ver qué ha
pasado con el precio de las casas
y también con la deuda de las familias
y como os podéis imaginar esto es algo
que ha disparado todas las alarmas
y es que como algunos expertos aventuran
canadá puede estar a punto de
enfrentarse a la explosión de una
burbuja inmobiliaria con todas sus
consecuencias sobre la economía y las
finanzas
al fin y al cabo casi el 7 por ciento de
los empleos en este país están en la
construcción y gracias a este boom
hipotecario tres bancos canadienses se
han situado entre los 20 más grandes del
mundo
de hecho amigos un dato el valor de
mercado del royal bank of canada es más
grande que cualquier banco de la zona
euro así que la pregunta es estaremos
ante una burbuja a punto de explotar
desde luego esta es una de las
prioridades hoy del gobierno impulsar
otros sectores tratar de enfriar el
sector inmobiliario y mantener en la
medida de lo posible una demanda capaz
de estabilizar el mercado tal vez la
intención de incrementar en un 50 por
ciento la llegada de inmigrantes cada
año tenga mucho que ver con todo esto al
fin y al cabo más inmigrantes supone más
demanda de viviendas de todas formas ojo
porque otros expertos recuerdan que los
bancos canadienses no se vieron
afectados por la crisis de 2008 y que
son bastante más robustos que otros
bancos internacionales además que
también recuerdan que la economía de
canadá parece marchar bien y que de
hecho está cogiendo fuerza tras un par
de años regulares
en fin el tiempo dirá pero desde luego
este es un riesgo que tiene el gobierno
muy muy pendiente y de la economía
amigos pasamos a los servicios públicos
[Música]
las listas de espera
en canadá la sanidad es un servicio
público gestionado y financiado por el
gobierno con los impuestos de los
contribuyentes claro de hecho este
sistema es considerado uno de los
mejores del mundo sin embargo también
tienen algunos problemas que empiezan a
ser pesados el más importante sin duda
es el de las listas de espera fijaos
según estudios del instituto fraser si
queréis ver a un especialista vais a
tener que esperar de media 18 semanas
más de cuatro meses un tiempo que además
no ha parado de crecer y es que ni el
envejecimiento demográfico ni el
incremento de la esperanza de vida
juegan a su favor todo esto ha provocado
que cada año decenas de miles de
canadienses se desplacen a eeuu para
recibir atención médica y que incluso se
haya hecho relativamente popular
contratar seguros médicos en el país
vecino en fin estos son los principales
retos y amenazas a los que se enfrenta
el gobierno de just in crudo como decía
en el vídeo anterior no todo es siempre
tan bonito como parece eso si el
resultado final del cóctel canadiense
parece bastante bueno en fin turno para
ti te gustaría vivir y trabajar
temporada en canadá déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y suscríbete a
visual político y ojo recuerda si
quieres conocer el mejor lado de canadá
no te pierdas este vídeo un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]